hey guys this is Pete peppers from candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda saga level for sixty
walked through with some commentary and
tips this is the hardest level for me in
the last episode so I wanted to go ahead
and add some tips to it because I know
it's given other people problems as well
the main thing that unfortunately the
main strategy is kind of to get these
dark purple candies to working in your
favor and that does require a little bit
of the way that they fall to help you
out but there's other things you can do
to try to get a better chance for those
things to happen so I'm gonna start
through this and start talking about
some of the important decisions in the
very beginning you want to get rid of
this top part this is a nice little way
to do that it worked out pretty well the
reason is because you don't really have
a lot of room till you get that little
top a few pieces so we're gonna want to
make as far as specials we're gonna want
to make we're gonna set up you know wrap
candies like I did right there and we're
gonna want to look for combos with those
obviously but also then stripes and
stripes going down or good in the very
beginning and then horizontal stripes
with fish will be good when we have to
blast that whole row at the bottom I had
a lot of trouble like I said the first
time I played this and I think one of
the things I was doing wrong was I was I
was reluctant to match the Purple's the
dark purple ones when they were out
there and I think over time I just
realized that you know they're gonna
fall if you if you make other matches so
just go ahead and get them out of the
way if that's one of the matches that
you have so so far we're doing pretty
well actually nothing exciting has
happened but we moved straight down the
middle and haven't had to waste a lot of
moves to this point so that's pretty
good so now we want to take our time you
can't really rush through this anytime
we can get that that match right there
with the where it's gonna shoot the
vertical 4-way a shot with the dark
purple we want to do and we want to make
other matches that are gonna create like
cascades because those will sometimes
fall right from the top
just as is so III right there all I did
was I just put one more green one
against the honey because I know I'm
gonna use the sparkle shell or a
sprinkle shell for the green candy
that's another vertical stripe will be
good here and you can see we have a lot
of purple on here just we can't really
make a match with them right now
I mean this is another one of those
cases where if you can't set something
up with it then just get it out of the
way and lots of new ones fall
so right around here you start to get a
little worried you know if you played it
before you know that it's really hard to
get those last two rows at the bottom
we're kind of stuck so we just want to
think about all the different options
first before we actually go through with
it
and you can see there that you know if I
would have moved those out of there
earlier they probably would have been a
better way to go here I'm gonna drop
this dark purple down they try to make a
color bomb match with this and I made
the wrapped candy first because I knew
it was gonna do that right there here we
have a choice to make a tea or striped I
went with the stripes because it would
just clear out more space and then you
see we got another stripe that fell and
on both the different times whenever I
beat this so far that that's always been
a big help is to get those dark purple
candy stripes to fall as we're watching
the candies cascade here I think the the
t-shaped is fine or the l-shaped and so
now we have eight moves and we're
looking pretty good we still have five
bears and we can't even see some of them
yet but we have the whole middle spread
out and that gives us a lot of a lot of
room to work because now we can work on
up and down the specials but also
side-to-side specials so I think look if
you get yourself to this point and you
have this much room that if you do take
your time and really plan things out you
should be able to finish Fischer start
will start to be useful now since we
have only of five bears to get but we
want to look for matches that are gonna
make the most destruction as possible
and we still want to get those cascades
to happen like we've been doing
so my sprinkle shell here will give us a
pretty good shot with blue and we will
load it back up so that's why I did that
it's like I get two extra moves here and
I went ahead and decided to go ahead and
make a couple specials before I used it
the second time because they're gonna
damage the other see like the red will
shoot across and hit the other side and
so on and so forth so now we have three
moves three bears and we can see them
all
and there you can see it on the first
move I actually waited and now I can use
my sprinkle to hit the two orange and
those fish are gonna go over there and
finish that off for me so you could see
that look I said I'd kind of I kind of
had a quick hit on it but I also wanted
to get a little bit of a cascade so I
thought about it and I thought that
making the other match would work out
better and it did and there we got it so
it's a frustrating level like I said and
there's no real clear-cut thing but just
take your time you know work on the
honey and make sure that you use the
sprinkle shell and think about how you
can get the biggest cascades going at
all times don't sit on those dark purple
candies too long if they're not gonna
set up a nice match then just get them
out of the way and get more things to
fall and sooner or later you'll get it
so I hope this helps please like this
video please subscribe to our channel so
you can find more of these that you know
we put them out all the time and we find
that they help and we hope you like them
too so I'll be making more soon if you
have any more questions leave a comment
Thanks